hello creatures of the internet i'm dave
rubin this is the reuben report direct
message i'm back in studio it's december
1st 2021 we're live streaming on rumble
youtube and blaze tv and i did all that
with one breath pretty good uh i am back
sorry i missed you on monday and tuesday
had to go to florida had my reasons
you know what i mean i was doing
business in florida had some things to
do and if you don't believe that i was
in the great state of florida connor can
we pull up the image that will prove it
that is me that is my hand and i am
drinking a venti iced coffee
from starbucks now before i get attacked
why are you supporting starbucks why
didn't you support one of the many cuban
coffee places i had a lot of cuban
coffee i think that place
called havana coffee or something in
wynwood amazing coffee but this was just
an emergency coffee in the morning near
the hotel
it was a starbucks inside a target
that's the way they do it over there in
florida it's fantastic so you can get a
coffee
and you can get like gift wrap and a pen
and diapers or whatever you want all at
once back to the image please we still
got the image up over there okay uh and
the reason i'm showing you that as proof
that i was in florida is as you can see
that is a plastic straw that's right
people plastic straws still are out
there they have not been banned
completely and i drank
that iced coffee over the course of
about an hour i sipped i enjoyed
i walked down the street
loved every second of it it did not
sort of crumble and it did not get a
little papery in the mouth i was able to
drink the iced coffee as long as i
wanted i could pull up the image one
more time there was a little confusion
because i posted this image
on the locals community and on twitter
and uh people were noting that the name
on the cup is gabe and a lot of people
were asking well who's this gabe fella
dave were you with someone named gabe
who is gabe what is this all about and
uh i just want to be clear that that is
my cup i don't want the conspiracy
theorists you know what i mean this is
where the internet and the uh conspiracy
theorists you can go down many rabbit
holes on the internet i just want to be
very clear i said dave and apparently
the guy heard gabe so i think you can
understand how that would be possible he
said what's your name
sir
dave gabe
you know so just to be clear anyway i
was in florida it was amazing i'll give
you a little hint about florida we are
opening uh a local studio as you guys
know we we moved the company down to
miami now we are opening a studio so
content creators
will be able to do podcasts and video
shows and all sorts of stuff we checked
out the studio space it's awesome we're
going to design the whole thing and i
think maybe some other reasons i had my
reasons i don't have to tell you
everything like who are you you know
what i mean maybe uh some more stuff
will be announced pretty soon i don't
know anything's possible guys we got
four stories for you today uh this cuomo
guy you know this chris cuomo over on
the clown network that is cnn he's a
journalist of sorts uh and it turns out
that basically he was coordinating his
news reports with his brother and the
campaign or the administration his
brother of course andrew cuomo former
governor of new york was stepped down uh
because of some sexual
assault allegations but cuomo was
basically coaching the guy and you can't
do that if you're a journalist you can
do it if you're a journalist so i'm a
little confused as to what cnn's upset
by here
but he is temporarily suspended will he
have a comeback like jeffrey toobin who
masturbated on a zoom call we'll find
out oh you can't say masturbating on ah
damn demonetized already sorry chris uh
that's story number one story number two
you guys know my feelings i'm not doing
any more just like the general
obsessive depressing covid stuff but i
will call out these ridiculously evil
awful politicians when they flaunt their
own rules right in front of us nancy
pelosi of course at a big event in dc uh
over the last couple of days unmasked in
a huge crowd and gavin newsom who's the
biggest douchebag in america
we should have had an image of a large
douchebag i'm honestly not sure what a
douchebag looks like truly i don't want
people googling it right now
but he's a horrible horrible person he's
the governor
of california he announced about two
weeks ago that he's extending his
emergency powers much like emperor
palpatine in revenge of the sith and
then of course he went on vacation to
cabo mexico where he was masterless with
his family in a 29
000
a night villa
and by reports he spent over 200 grand
on this vacation so we'll get into that
he is a giant giant douchebag
then uh on this channel cnbc which is c
uh nbc's business channel they've got
this guy jim cramer he's always yelling
at the camera and you know really just
sort of like over the top whatever i'm
sort of indifferent to him altogether
but he went on a crazy possibly drunken
rampage about anti-vaxxed people
yesterday and it just sort of unmasked
like what lies beneath all of these
people who pretend they're so tolerant
really just bananas and then the white
house has some new coveted policy which
i'm just gonna mock relentlessly anyway
i'm in a great mood i'm glad to be here
got a little florida sunshine here we go
so yes chris cuomo the brother of
disgraced governor from new york andrew
cuomo he has been suspended
by cnn
not that anyone's watching cnn but i
still felt it would be kind of fun to do
this story we've got some info here from
the daily wire cnn suspended host chris
cuomo on tuesday over new details that
were revealed this week about the amount
of help that he allegedly provided to
his brother while his brother was the
democrat governor of new york and facing
accusations of sexual misconduct the new
york times reported that while chris
cuomo had apologized for advising his
brother
quote thousands of pages of new evidence
released on monday by the new york
attorney general leticia james revealed
that the anchor's role had been more
intimate and involved than previously
known and quote in a statement cnn said
the documents which were not privy to
which we were not privy to before their
public release raised serious questions
when chris admitted to us that he had
offered advice to his brother's staff he
broke our rules and we acknowledged that
publicly but we also appreciated the
unique position he was in and understood
his need to put family first and jobs
second however these documents point to
a greater level of involvement in his
brother's efforts than we previously
knew as a result we have suspended chris
indefinitely
pending further evaluation so we've got
a little more from yahoo but before i
get to that actually let's just sort of
unpack where we're at with this thing so
as you all know andrew cuomo had all of
these allegations of sexual assault
sort of just popping up every couple
days and you may remember if you were
watching this show that i kept saying
all along that allegations are just
allegations and until there's proof
until there's sort of critical mass
until he admits something or someone has
a photo or something like that we should
treat it as such i don't like andrew
cuomo i think he was a bad governor
i think he did some horrific things
related to kovid while the media was
cheering him along the entire time but
you know we don't all want to just be
taken out by allegations so you have to
be careful right like you have to be
careful where you point because if it's
not true and you're pointing over there
well eventually it's probably uh going
to come for you now the idea here that
cnn
cares
sort of what chris cuomo does
journalistically is kind of interesting
to me because they pretend that he's a
journalist and he's not a journalist a
journalist would be out in the field
fact-finding honestly analyzing
information and presenting it in an
unbiased fashion to the people chris
cuomo is a guy who sits at a desk and
basically tells you his opinion while
pretending he's not telling you his
opinion now you might be looking at me
and going dave what do you mean you're a
guy sitting at a desk and you're telling
us your opinion yes and i'm telling you
i'm telling you my opinion right we're
doing this man and it's all good i'm not
pretending to be something i'm not but
if you don't think that chris cuomo is
obviously a democrat and a liberal and
someone that is
in cahoots with that side of the aisle
while pretending to be impartial then
i'm just not sure what to tell you and
by the way that goes for don lemon that
goes for wolf blitzer that goes for jake
tapper that goes for jim acosta it goes
for all of them right they're all
democrats obviously like there's just no
doubt they cover certain stories when it
makes republicans look bad and when the
same exact things happen
to
democrats they don't cover those things
like that's just how it works as a
matter of fact someone pointed out on
twitter
that after the incident in wisconsin you
know the car ramming incident by
basically by a black supremacist who
killed i think how many it's up to seven
people maimed many more uh that jake
tapper had not tweeted once about it in
days so i don't know if he has in the
last two or three days but i had seen
that from a few days ago it's like why
wouldn't you tweet about that jake and
it's because it doesn't fit the
narrative that jake wants if it had been
a trump supporter of obviously plowing
into a bunch of black people of course
jake's going to wrote that so they're
all pretending to be journalists when
they are the furthest thing from
journalists they are activists they are
digital assassins who work with the
democrats it's as simple as that so the
question now is sort of what should cnn
do now cnn's ratings are so bad that to
me it's like you just fire the guy like
why are you held hostage with this guy
get rid of him hire somebody else get
your diversity and inclusion and equity
team find a trans able or disabled
lesbian the lazy eye maybe a [ __ ] the
whole thing and put them on air and most
likely you'll get better rating i'd
watch that show honestly i would watch
that show but the ratings have been uh
pretty terrible for chris cuomo for a
while so it's like why would he get why
would he have the white privilege that
would be white privilege right if he
came back if they brought him back it's
like two been masturbated on a zoom call
with
you know his other his employees right
he wasn't on air but he was on azuko
with other co-workers and they brought
him back it's like well that seems like
white privilege too why not hire someone
else like what is it that that these
people have that is so great that sorry
you can't show your penis to your
co-workers guys i want to be very clear
about that okay you can't do it okay so
it's like why do these people get to
come back so for a little bit on the
numbers of chris cuomo this is from
yahoo just a couple weeks ago
in total chris cuomo's 9 pm eastern
program pulled in 684 000 total average
viewers
last week for comparison the 9 p.m fox
news rival sean hannity pulled in an
average of
3.486 million viewers so the point is
not a lot of people are watching these
shows i actually think cuomo might be
the highest rated guy on cnn but their
numbers are still terrible i mean 684
thousand people our clip of
me talking about joy behar last week has
something like 700 000 views i got two
guys in here we're having shake shack
for lunch by the way guys so i'm not
saying i don't have a staff that's
working hard and everything else but
these people have huge budgets they have
a gajillion people for work that work
for them and they're just peddling
nonsense so
i guess at the end of the day i don't
really care whether he comes or goes
because i don't think you should be
watching him anyway
but it is sort of interesting just
watching the kind of machinations of how
a giant corporation has to deal with
their own nonsense as they as they sort
of
as it becomes public in essence guys
before we get to story number two i want
to talk to you about raycon because i
don't know if you know this but the
holidays are officially here and if
you're like me and if you prefer prefer
chilling at home with family uh to the
chaos of hitting the stores for the
latest sales then you probably prefer
doing your holiday shopping online i
don't leave the house so today you can
save big on a gift your loved ones will
use everyday rakon wireless earbuds
whether i'm listening to them while i'm
doing my daily cardio or i have them
with me on the plane when i'm flying to
an event i like to keep my raycons close
with seamless bluetooth pairing and a
comfortable noise isolating fit you too
can start listening right away and keep
listening for hours the audio quality is
amazing comparable to what you get from
other premium brands except raycon
starts at half the price
the new everyday earbuds come with three
new sound profiles to make sure
everything you're listening to sounds
it's best with just the right amount of
bass set them to balance mode when
you're catching up on episodes of the
reuben report raycon offers eight hours
of play time and a 32-hour battery life
there's also a built-in mic and you can
take calls on your earbuds at the press
of a button so this holiday season give
your loved ones a gift they can use
every day for calls or music for work or
play at home or on the go go to buy
recon dot com slash reuben today to
unlock exclusive deals for up to 30 off
your rake on order but hurry this offer
is only for a limited time and you don't
want to miss that's by raycon dot com
reuben to unlock up to 30 percent off
your raycons by raycon.com
reuben and now back to me
all right you guys know my policy on the
covid stuff like now they got the
omicron variant which i'm told is the
younger brother of the unicron variant
that was the planet in the transformers
movie from 1985 voiced by orson welles
that destroyed cybertron and created a
whole thing yeah yeah i know they got
another variant put on more masks wrap
your head in saran wrap okay blah blah
blah
i'm kind of over the kova thing i was
just in florida nobody has covered
everyone's happy we went to a restaurant
guys if i'm lying right now i want you
to yell something we went to a
restaurant did people smile people were
smiling literally the waitress smiled it
was incredible i had not seen the lower
half of anyone's face and a while i
freaked out for a second just realized
she was smiling at me he was amazing um
so i'm done with just the usual covert
stories if you want to wrap your head in
a plastic forever if you want to get
injected every week that's great go
ahead fantastic more power to you but i
will call out the hypocrisy of these
ridiculous uh evil they are evil at this
point politicians who are demanding that
we inject our children with things and
keep young people in masks and all of
this nonsense and all of the [ __ ]
that we all know while they don't do it
themselves so here's nancy pelosi
at an event in dc and nancy
where's your mask nancy you're in a
closed air space room with other people
you're ancient
lady like you gotta keep that mask on
and less weight could it be that you
don't even believe
that there's a problem and you're just a
[ __ ] artist who wants to control
your constituents and everyone else in
america could that possibly it all right
so that's just one image of old nancy i
don't really care about her but gavin
newsom who is a
horrible horrible human being he just is
he is an evil disney cartoon character
villain i don't like him very much and
larry elder should be the governor of
california alas here we are well gavin
newsom a couple weeks ago uh extended
his emergency powers right he because oh
my god he's got to have more power this
freak well what did he do he extended
his emergency powers and then he went on
vacation to cabo san lucas in mexico and
i think we've got some info on this this
is from the california globe the globe
has received several photos and a now
removed tweet from sources who were in
cabo san lucas in the mexican state of
baja california sir over thanksgiving at
the time california governor gavin
newsom and his family vacationed the
sources say that the newsome stayed at
stayed nearby at a 23 to 29 000 per
night villa la dacha cabo san lucas
villa owned by russian entrepreneur and
businessman oleg tinkov the sources said
from their rental they could see the 10
000 to 12 000 square foot villa and said
that it comes with two chefs four to
five servers personal trainers and the
like gavin governor newsome just
extended california's covid state of
emergency into its second year and
recently ordered all students ages 5 to
11 to receive vaccinations in order to
attend in-person school mass mandates
and vaccine requirements are still in
place newsom was paid 209 000 in 2020 as
governor of california we heard back
from the governor's press secretary
later in the day
katie this was a personal trip paid for
by the family she called the globe and
again said that the newsome family paid
for the villa in cabo we asked what
newsomes she finally said the governor
paid for
a personal trip okay so i'm not even
making this about whether he paid for it
personally not he's got a ton of money
he's loosely related to um
to pelosi somehow i don't know how he's
made all his money like these people
have obscene amounts of money like i
have no doubt that it's all a freaking
ponzi scheme and god knows what they're
pulling but i'll assume he didn't do
this on the state dime but the fact that
he's basically staying for several
nights at a 30 000 villa in cabo after
uh saying that this place california
should remain in a state of emergency
like he's a hypocrite he's a liar he's
evil
you and you know we should do a little
choose your own adventure for the show
day whatever adjective you want for this
douchebag you just put it in there he's
just
awful like
the amount of money but to extend like
if you really believed it was a state of
emergency gav wouldn't you be here doing
emergency stuff you wouldn't be going to
cabo
okay i've been to cabo
pretty good it is pretty good but i
never stayed at a 30 000 a night thing
that would be nice that would really be
great anyway there were some pictures of
him doing this it sounds like that the
the cost of the thing for the family was
at least 203 thousand dollars if not
more i have no doubt they didn't wear
masks but all their servants of course
wore masks that's how it works um and
this is the same guy who of course as
you know went to french laundry one of
the most expensive restaurants in the
united states at the height of the
pandemic with a bunch of
lobbyists and he didn't wear a mask and
they spent i think 10 or 12 grand on
booze i mean he's just absolutely
horrible and you know these guys should
just have nothing to do with your life
they should their decisions should have
nothing to do with your life go live
your life and be happy people
all right cnbc which is a
financial news network on the television
uh they've got this jim cramer guy and
you know jim cramer even if you're not a
cnbc guy he's this bald guy he's always
screaming at the television and you know
ranting and he gets close to the camera
and he gets further and he's this way
and that way this guy's a real piece of
work i'm sort of indifferent to him i
don't really i don't really care about
the markets in that way it's not really
my thing but he went on a completely i
mean this is a completely
unhinged
coveted rant and you tell me if he's on
drugs or drunk i mean something ain't
right here
lord knows what happened if you didn't
partake but back then anyone who refused
to get vaccinated would get ratted out
immediately because we knew that person
could hurt other people the common wheel
was
a common will
now we're engaged in a similar struggle
with covid and eisenhower would be
aghast we have immunocompromised people
who are incubators for every variant to
come
walking around lawfully unvaccinated
that's psychotic
we have companies that have tried hard
to get people vaccinated not backing
down we have governors who want to be
president by grandstanding on a foolish
states right issue the right to get sick
and get other people sick
so it's time to admit that we have to go
to war against covet require vaccination
universally have the military run it if
you don't want to get vaccinated you
better be ready to prove your
conscientious
status in court and even then you need
to help in the war effort by staying
home until we finally beat this thing
all right he's just a random lunatic
like just some ranting raving nut bag
but a couple points there uh first off
this idea that the unvaccinated are
hurting vaccinated people
um well if the vaccines worked as
promised
then if you were unvaccinated you'd be
making a choice for yourself but you
wouldn't be able to infect a vaccinated
person because the vaccine by definition
would be stopping transmission of the
virus now we know that that's not true
by the way lebron james who has been
vaccinated for quite some time and he's
a big vax guy and he loves china and
he's a good us citizen because he does
whatever is politically correct uh he
has cobit now okay so obviously the
vaccines don't work as promised you all
know that which is why they're doing 87
boosters and again wrap your head in
saran wrap i should i'm not a big into
the markets guy but i should invest in
saran wrap can we let's get some saran
wrap i don't know are they publicly
traded is that a thing um
then cramer who is a money guy right
he's a markets guy a financial guy he's
upset at the companies backing down from
mandates i mean that's just absolutely
ridiculous if you want companies to be
able to make decisions
for themselves i mean just
patently absurd and by the way the
courts have said that biden's mandate
for these companies is
unconstitutional and they're going to
debate this in the courts but right now
companies are not being forced by the
federal government and as you know this
is a court case that's being led by the
daily wire my friend harmeet dillon uh
is the lead lawyer on this like this is
now up in the air as to whether
companies can do this at all then he he
mocks states rights
which is basically the most important
part of our federalist system that you
can move to different states that are
more in line with your views but he's a
power hungry maniac which is what these
people are i mean they're all unmasking
themselves at all times guys if you just
give them the power if you would just
give the structure above us the power
would we all just behave better and then
we'd be safe because that really seems
like it's going to work doesn't it that
seems like it's going to work
and then finally he wants to get the
military involved because that always
works too right like maybe we should
just like force a bunch of people who
are you know infected to take special
showers maybe put them in camp somewhere
with that would that be good for you jim
cramer [ __ ] uh and finally one more
story for you i feel like i had a lot of
coffee today like i'm i'm really feeling
like or maybe the story's just brought
it out of me today i don't know or is
florida i don't know feeling good i got
a little vitamin d who knows um we've
got some new white house covid policy
and again
this was i debated this morning you know
i don't want to talk about the
ridiculousness of covid unless i'm going
to purely
mock it that is going to be my policy
going forward uh here's peter ducey this
is fox news this is an actual journalist
this is a guy who goes to these
ridiculous white house press conferences
led by that crazy woman jen saki and
actually and uh asks questions and
follows up this is this is a good guy
that's peter ducey um he is now
reporting this is from yesterday that
the white house has their strictest
lockdown measures on the way take a look
it sounds like on thursday according to
the washington post and we've we're
we have made contact with some white
house folks they are going to announce
some of the strictest coveted
regulations yet on american citizens
including according to the washington
post requiring all americans who return
from abroad to quarantine in their house
for
up to seven days
if that is something that they're going
to propose in this speech on thursday
there are a lot of questions how do you
enforce that do you send somebody to the
door of somebody that just came back
from overseas regardless of vaccination
status or testing status to make sure
that they are home and also does that
apply to everybody coming into the
country not just folks who come and
document it uh
at an airport but also be undocumented
okay so that was peter ducey yesterday
now it sounds like some of the measures
that they plan on bringing in uh are
being leaked right now but i don't want
to go too far on that just yet because
as he said they're gonna supposedly
announce this stuff on thursday so if by
show time tomorrow they've announced it
obviously we'll talk about that then
but this one that he talked about that
americans coming back from abroad are
basically going to be told to quarantine
and it sounds like it will be uh
irregardless as the kids say um uh where
as to whether you're vaccinated or not
they're gonna make you homecorny i mean
this is just nonsense it's just nonsense
they know no one's gonna do it
it's all [ __ ] like if you i just
i think i've had just like the full-on
like if there was any like bit of the
red bill that i had not swallowed or
snorted at this point i'm pretty sure
after a couple of extra days in florida
uh the last few days like it's just
there like this is these people are
never gonna stop and all we have to do
to get them to stop is say no more i
won't comply i'm going to live my life
i'm not going to quarantine if i'm not
sick i'm going to make decisions for
myself i'm not going to fire people
just because they don't do what medical
decisions i want i'm not going to be an
endless relentless hysterical
authoritarian prick like you'd like us
all to be
but we will find out we will find out
and uh remember all of this of course is
coming from the federal government led
by joe biden and uh you know he's a fine
he seems fine right there's nothing
wrong with that guy so
obviously they're doing it for your own
good people
all right a couple comments from the
locals community and by the way you can
if you haven't joined yet you can live
chat with other audience members and
possibly get me messages during the show
if you just go to
reubenreport.locals.com or download the
locals app on the apple app store or on
google play bionic bacon great name says
i love my ray cons excellent glad to
hear it joe says we don't do the coveted
thing in florida anymore ain't it the
truth ain't it the truth i mean they
just don't and it's just fine you know
it's really it's just fine it's gonna be
okay people and tk says the omicron
variant turns everyone into fouchy jesus
it's gonna freak me out at the end of
the show there i'm reading these live
you know the omicron variant like
omicron unicron megatron
next up starscream like it's all
nonsense
nonsense guys part one and part two of
my interview with former police officer
brandon tatum uh and co-founder of the
blexit movement alongside candice owens
uh those are up right now on the youtube
and of course you can get the full
episode ad free and early at
room.locals.com
uh this is a big week for several
reasons um so i'm i got a lot to do
today we're gonna we're having shake
shack for lunch so uh hope you enjoyed
the show i did
how is it if uh if a host says that they
enjoyed the show
is that that's okay right like that i
feel like that's a cuomo movie i really
thought i was great today
all right see ya